[Music]  testing 1 2 3  we're on we're here to investigate a  patient that killed three innocent  teenagers on a Halloween in 1978 he was  shot by his own psychiatrist and taken  into custody that night and spent the  last 40 years in captivity  hello Michael I have something you might  like to see  everyone in my family like turns into a  nutcase this time of year I mean your  grandmother is Laurie Strode she was  almost a murdered wasn't it her brother  converted all those babysitters yeah  there was not her brother that's the  meaning people made up Tino's head I  pray every night that he would escape  hey Belle did you do that for so I can  kill him the bus crashed  what bus crash Michael escaped  excuse me somebody's in here it's waited  for this night who's waiting for me  I waited for whom  you don't believe in the boogeyman  [Music]  you should to close the closet door  [Music]